[Music]
so
hey fresh family it's mark ellis and
welcome to another episode of rt
essentials you might think you have a
pretty solid handle on the resident evil
films milo jovovich ugly mutants a lot
of gun play some rams theme songs and
you're good to go but after seven films
there's actually a whole lot more going
on with this franchise you got a wide
variety of approaches to the narrative
villains tones settings and occasionally
crafty references back to this source
material and yes some crystal method
songs as well it's a rich robust blend
but before we start i gotta throw up the
spoiler warning because we will
basically be going over the plot of each
film so you have been warned without
further ado here's our rt essentials
guide to the history of the resident
evil live action movie franchise
resident evil
[Music]
hey
the very first resident evil film hit
theaters in 2002 and comes from writer
director paul w s anderson not to be
confused with the other paul anderson
this is the one who set the video game
adaptation gold standard with his 1995
big screen take on mortal kombat the
kickoff to the re franchise still has
the highest audience score of the entire
series with a 67
fresh rating it's also holding on to the
second highest tomato meter score from
rt approved critics at 36
that's still very rotten but hey it
could be worse the movie opens with a
brief introduction to the umbrella
corporation the world's largest business
conglomerate commanding a tremendous
amount of economic and political
influence around the globe and wouldn't
you know even though umbrella has a
pleasant and widely trusted public face
they also secretly dabble in all kinds
of unethical covert research into
military technology bioweaponry and
genetic experimentation you got to keep
the shareholders happy am i right
though umbrella's hometown of raccoon
city gets explored in later entries in
the series the first film mainly takes
place in just two locations a mysterious
home known as the spencer mansion and
the massive secret lap hidden underneath
known as the hive that's where umbrella
scientists are working on the
genetically engineered t virus which can
grant people all kinds of supernatural
powers but also has that little downside
of you know turning them into monstrous
zombie-like undead creatures of the
night might hold up the fda approval
just a bit turning your subjects into an
unholy abomination it's sort of a red
flag the movie opens with alice played
by mila jovovich waking up in the
spencer mansion with no memory and
eventually making her way into the hive
we ultimately learned that she was part
of a plot involving some environmental
activists to break into the hive and
steal a copy of the t-virus but things
went about as wrong as they could
possibly go the virus was accidentally
unleashed and almost everyone in the
complex became a homicidal mutant terror
the hive has been locked down by
umbrella's artificially intelligent
control program known as the red queen
and the rest of the movie finds alice
and a few other much less important
survivors attempting to locate an
anti-viral solution before escaping the
hive the film ends with alice getting
out alone only to find that all of
raccoon city has been overrun and
destroyed i mean it is raccoon city so
you expect a few trash cans to be
knocked over obviously the umbrella
corps raccoon city and the t-virus are
all core concepts from the video games
but the story also lists the spencer
mansion and a secret lap hidden beneath
directly from the first resident evil
video game there are also some notable
easter eggs and quick references for
eagle-eyed resident evil fans a police
cruiser bears the logo for stars
s-t-a-r-s raccoon city's special tactics
and rescue squad the doctored photos
alice finds in the mansion showing her
wedding day directly recalls similar
photos featured in that very first game
the hives underground train was directly
inspired by a sequence from resident
evil 2 and finally a copy of the raccoon
city times has the headline horrid
raccoon more victims dead a direct lift
from the intro to the first game also
kind of editorializing there let's keep
it unbiased newspapers resident evil
apocalypse
we move directly from a film with some
of the highest ratings for the entire
resident evil series to one of the
lowest ranked entries the 2004 sequel
apocalypse scored a 19
on the tomato meter making it the
critic's pick for the most rotten of all
the re films and that's saying something
because according to the tomato meter
this series not exactly toy story
apocalypse draws key inspiration from
the two games that were most recently
released back in 2004 resident evil 3
nemesis and resident evil code veronica
the shootout between umbrella's military
force the raccoon police stars and the
undead mirrors a scene from the resident
evil 3 intro at several points and a
sequence in which alice running from a
helicopter and using her weapon to
detonate a series of explosive recreates
the opening cut scene from code veronica
[Music]
the first film was considered a
financial success so the budget for the
sequel was expanded to 50 million
dollars 11 million over the original
paul w s anderson once again worked on
the script but passed along directing
duties to alexander witt while he kicked
off yet another franchise alien vs
predator whit was an accomplished second
unit director who worked on numerous
bond films and had collaborated with
ridley scott on multiple projects in the
past in fact he made sure to include a
lot of helicopters in apocalypse because
he enjoyed working with them so much
during ridley's black hawk down shoot
apocalypse opens with raccoon city under
strict quarantine to prevent the spread
of the zombie infection actress sienna
gilroy is introduced as central game
character jill valentine a disgraced
operative with raccoon city pd's special
tactics and rescue squad you know the
stars the filmmakers felt strongly that
galore should wear joe's familiar
costume from the game in the movie
despite it not being particularly
realistic for a police officer so they
added some dialogue about a heat wave to
help explain it oh dead fur also
co-stars as carlos oliveira a character
introduced in the game resident evil 3
but he wears a totally different costume
in the film so i guess it was a lot less
hot where he was
i know
i count three of them
they got us boxed then
the film's primary nemesis is alice's
old pal matt addison who's been horribly
mutated into the villain nemesis and has
been tasked by umbrella with tracking
her down the film ends with the nemesis
switching sides to help alice and dying
in a blaze of glory while fighting
umbrella troops as the company detonates
a nuclear bomb over the city though
alice appears to have been killed in the
blast she wakes up in another research
facility with newly developed
telekinetic powers brought on by
exposure to the t virus and manages to
escape that is before we see indications
that she's now part of something called
program alice and an essential key to
umbrella's future plans we also find out
in this film that the t virus was
accidentally created by umbrella
scientist dr charles ashford played by
jared harris who is attempting to cure
his daughter angela's genetic disability
the ashfords are named in honor of the
ashford family from the video game
series the initial plan was also to make
angela the model for the hive's ai
protector the red queen but this concept
was ultimately abandoned and cut from
the final film in fact this entire dr
ashford origin story for the t-virus
will ultimately be retconned in the film
the final chapter more on that in a bit
resident evil extinction
[Music]
come on
anderson returned once more to write the
third re film 2007's extinction but this
time handed directing duties over to
australian russell mulcahy best known
for the original 1986 highlander he's
the go-to guy if your franchise features
immortal characters i suppose the film
opens five years after apocalypse after
the t-virus has gone worldwide and
triggered a global apocalypse because
the virus is fatal to so many kinds of
organisms it has also turned the surface
of much of the planet into a desert
which is a huge bummer human refugees
have largely abandoned cities and
started living in mobile convoys to stay
ahead of the migrating undead this makes
it the first film in the franchise to
fully break with the established series
chronology the most recent game resident
evil 4 came out in 2005 but it's set in
a world that has not yet been totally
overrun by the undead or transformed
into a desert alice whose t-virus
infection has rendered her a full-on
super soldier by this point is traveling
alone and finds a journal indicating
that settlement in alaska called arcadia
may still be zombie free she hooks up
with a group of survivors including old
friends carlos and lj from apocalypse
and game character claire redfield and
convinces them to travel north with her
carl as we should note is given his
recognizable costume from resident evil
3 in this film which he didn't sport in
the previous entry
[Music]
meanwhile back at umbrella the evil dr
alexander isaacs who is not from the
games but whose name was inspired by
frequent paul w s anderson collaborator
jason isaacs is trying to clone alice to
recreate her psychic powers he tests the
clones in a mock-up of the mansion and
hide from the first film but so far none
have survived ultimately he determines
that he needs the original project alice
back in order to harvest her blood this
film also introduces us to umbrella
senior executive albert wesker another
character who was introduced in the very
first resident evil game way back in
1996. in the films he's umbrella's evil
chairman project alice the subject of
domestication
is of the highest priority we will
concentrate on this to the exclusion of
all other research
we'll expect an updated report within a
week alice's group clashes with
umbrella's forces in post-apocalyptic
las vegas where i hear tom jones is
still performing dr isaacs gets bitten
and transforms into a cinematic take on
the tyrant a familiar boss character
that appears in numerous re games carlos
sacrifices himself to clear a path for
the convoy who'll get into a chopper and
head for alaska alice meanwhile stays
behind in a vegas umbrella facility to
determine whether or not her blood
really can be used to create a t-virus
cure despite going in its own direction
extinction features a number of other
shoutouts to elements of the game and
established resident evil war dr isaac's
office for example features some of the
healing herbs that help restore playable
characters health meters in the games we
also get a memorable attack from some
genetically altered crows and
irritatingly familiar re foe anderson
said that his concept for the super
undead more intelligent coordinated
baddies was inspired by human enemies
known as ganados in resident evil 4
resident evil afterlife
chris and claire redfield
you've really become quite an
inconvenience for me
i told you i'd be bringing a few friends
paul w s anderson returned to the
director's chair for 2010's resident
evil afterlife and helmed all the series
remaining films starring milo jovovich
as alice this was also the first re film
to be shot in 3d anderson became
convinced to try the technology after
seeing advanced footage from james
cameron's avatar he and his crew then
spent two weeks during pre-production
just mastering their new 3d camera
system and also trying to find a role
for some nine foot tall blue aliens
afterlife includes another primary game
character wentworth miller as chris
redfield and also brings back ali larter
as claire redfield and sienna guillory
as jill valentine while debuting sean
roberts as the new albert wesker with a
new look more closely resembling his
game counterpart he replaces jason
o'mara who played wesker in extinction
notably this is chris redfield's only
appearance in all of the anderson
resident evil films aside from being
related to claire he has very little in
common with his game counterpart
afterlife is mostly based around
elements from the game resident evil 5
which came out the year before in 2009
the scarab like mind control devices and
the large-scale final confrontation with
wesker were all lifted more or less
directly from the game and the so-called
axe man mutant is visually based on the
game's executioner majini enemies
[Music]
[Music]
resident evil 5 largely concerns a new
illness impacting people infected by
parasites known as las plaguis but
because the film series wasn't yet
introducing this new concept all plaga
related mutations are credited once more
to our old friend the t-virus the story
of afterlife picks up one year after the
events of extinction and opens with
alice making good on her threat and
invading the tokyo umbrella headquarters
along with her army of clones during the
assault wesker injects her with
anti-virus robbing her of her
superpowers but they both manage to
escape before the facility is destroyed
six months later alice finally gets to
alaska to rejoin claire and the other
survivors the world seems to be slowly
coming back to life by this point it's
no longer a completely barren mad
max-esque hellscape there's even trees
again together they travel to los
angeles and hook up with another group
of survivors one of whom i hope includes
me living at a prison there oh prison
never mind i'm out
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
alice also discovers that arcadia is not
a refuge in alaska like she thought but
a ship that buries people along the
pacific coast the group manages to
escape the undead and reach the ship
only to find that it's actually owned by
umbrella and used to round up people for
dun dun further experimentation man they
really thought of everything those
umbrella folks too bad they're all just
so darn evil on board the group finds a
mutating whisker who needs regular
infusions of non-contaminated dna to
keep himself under control and vaguely
humanoid he greets alice with a familiar
line from the game you've really become
quite an inconvenience for me after an
extended fight wesker appears to die in
an explosion and everything seems to
have worked out itself for alice and our
heroes that is until a new squadron of
umbrella troops arrives led by a scarab
wearing jill valentine and attacks
it's a cliffhanger
resident evil retribution
[Applause]
as promised 2012's retribution picks up
right after that shocking afterlife
ending with a mind-controlled jill
valentine and a fleet of v-22 ospreys
attacking the survivors on the arcadia
fighter the fate of many characters from
afterlife are purposely left ambiguous
while alice is recaptured or isn't it by
this point like re-re-re-recaptured
part two of the sequel it's hard to keep
up anyway she awakens in yet another
umbrella facility which features
multiple areas made up to look like
different world cities simulating their
respective zombie outbreaks inside this
new facility claire will meet several
new characters from the games including
leon s kennedy aydah wong and barry
burton she'll also encounter a number of
dead characters who've returned as
clones like michelle rodriguez as rayne
ocampo an old hive ally from the very
first re film oh dead fur as carlos
olivieri and collin salmon as james one
shade upon arriving at central control
alice meets wong who's an agent working
for wesker they have an initial fight
closely modeled on a sequence from the
game resident evil 4.
i see you've made yourself at home
but i must say
it does have a certain ease to it
it seems both wong and wesker have
broken with umbrella now that the
company is actually being controlled by
the red queen the reactivated rogue ai
from the first resident evil film she's
trying to wipe out all humanity while
they're determined to ensure our future
survival so wait now wesker is a good
guy i guess but look do not get too
attached there's not a ton of loyalty in
this resident evil world probably
because there's just so many clones
walking around ultimately alice and her
new ally leon are able to destroy and
escape the new facility which it turns
out was underwater the whole time but
they're still being pursued by jill
valentine in a submarine along with an
evil clone of reyno campo alice rips the
mind control device off of jill's chest
restoring her to normal and the group
travels together to wesker's new
headquarters in a heavily fortified and
barricaded get this white house the film
does introduce the las pagas parasite
that was first established in the game
resident evil 5 but went unmentioned in
the previous film another sequence
involving zombies chasing a rolls-royce
phantom was inspired by a scene from
resident evil 5 but the vehicle was
originally a hummer in the game a hummer
into a rolls-royce phantom that's what
we in the biz call an upgrade
resident evil the final chapter
you're fast
but you're not too smart
[Music]
the djokovic anderson resident evil
chronology comes to a close in 2017's
the final chapter which means this is
one of the only horror movies with a
title like the final chapter and it
actually makes good on its promise i'm
looking right at you freddie's dead the
final nightmare the old school resident
evil series also went out on a high note
this is the highest grossing resident
evil film from the entire run to date
hauling in 312 million dollars on a 40
million dollar budget it also has the
highest tomato meter score from rt
approved critics with a strong
well strong guest 37 percent the film
opens with a flashback showing dr james
marcus founder of umbrella inventing the
t virus uh what about dr ashford you
might ask forget dr ashford dr marcus
uses his invention to save the life of
his daughter alicia but soon learns
about the virus's deadly side effects he
wants to destroy it right away but his
business partner dr isaacs instead hires
wesker to kill him and takes over the
company himself alicia later becomes the
model for the red queen the ai that
controls umbrella's operations the
character of james marcus was introduced
in the game resident evil 0 as one of
three founders of umbrella this dr mark
has always had dangerous and unethical
experiments in mind and was not
motivated by helping his daughter in the
game timeline he's also betrayed and
killed by wesker because i guess some
things never change jumping to some time
after the end of retribution alice is
now alone in washington dc after the
white house has been destroyed she's
attacked by two recognizable baddies
from the games a portly zombie known as
a javo from re6 and a flying capio from
resident evil 5.
she finds a bunker with weapons but it's
also equipped with a fax machine
allowing the red queen who's been
tracking her via satellite to
communicate the red queen says she is
also now fighting umbrella to save
humanity and wants to help alice
directing her back to the hive and a
supposed airborne cure for the t-virus
ever gabo anderson the real-life
daughter of milo djokovic and paul w s
anderson plays the red queen in the film
originally it was only going to be a
voice over role but the visual effects
team opted to actually record her on set
then digitally alter her appearance
rather than animating the character
entirely from scratch arriving back in
raccoon city after being chased by dr
isaacs in a tank alice meets back up
with claire redfield who's rounded up a
new group of survivors and taken refuge
in a skyscraper player's outfit in this
film by the way is lifted directly from
the one she wears in resident evil
revelations 2 of all the characters she
suffers the most for her fashion the
group survives more attacks by isaac
soldiers and some mutated dogs but
finally gets through to the hive using
the crater created by the nuclear
explosion in the second film remember
that finally alice and claire encounter
yet another version of dr isaacs this
one says he's the real dr isaac and the
one in the tank is a clone but he may
not be right about this and honestly at
this point who can keep track of all
these isaacs your little friend won't be
able to help you now you can't run
anymore
[Music]
i wasn't running
[Music]
dr isaacs also makes another shocking
revelation alice herself is a clone of
alicia marcus the daughter of umbrella
founder james marcus and the original
inspiration for the t-virus the real
original alicia is still alive and helps
her clone and claire blow up the hive
and release the airborne version of the
antivirus which will slowly return
everything to normal as it spreads
around the globe alisi also uploads
memories of her real childhood for alice
giving her some kind of sense for her
own backstory this film was purposely
designed to conclude alice's story but
give the producers an opening for more
installments in this timeline before
potentially rebooting the entire
franchise so it closes with alice
heading off to kill more monsters as the
t-virus slowly dies around the world
there were original plans to actually
kill off alice's character at the end of
the final chapter but djokovic wanted
her to have a happy ending and i'd say
she's earned it it's not easy to jump
backwards while firing two guns and hit
your target or anything for that matter
alice you deserve happiness
resident evil welcome to raccoon city
you see umbrella they have an incident
i'm talking chernobyl if you know what i
mean
[Music]
people are getting sick
[Music]
you gotta help us claire let the world
know what's really going on
2021's welcome to raccoon city
completely reboots the franchise with no
direct connections to the previous six
films it comes from writer director
johannes roberts who previously helmed
47 meters down and the strangers pray at
night plans for a reboot were already
underway while the final chapter was
still in theaters james wan had been
attached briefly as a producer but left
the project to work on the new mortal
kombat reboot instead greg russo worked
with juan on an early script idea he
also ended up on that mortal kombat
movie they were considering a new
project more directly inspired by
resident evil 7 biohazard and the focus
on a character suffering in isolation
roberts's film on the other hand is
directly based on the first two games in
the resident evil franchise and he was
particularly focused on capturing their
familiar range-soaked dark spooky
atmosphere with more focus on horror
than action he specifically cites the
2019 remake of resident evil 2 as his
main and direct visual and tonal
inspiration for the film
every story has a beginning
discover the origin of evil he even
experimented with restrictive camera
angles that mimic the look of a video
game so sometimes for example the film
employs a high angle that almost looks
like surveillance video which would be
unnatural in a film but familiar to a
gamer as well sometimes a character will
walk off screen and then disappear for a
while without having the camera follow
them raccoon city was also front loaded
with a lot of game characters who only
found their way into the djokovic films
gradually over time including kaya
scodolario as claire redfield robbie
amell as chris redfield hannah john
cayman as jill valentine evan jogia as
leon s kennedy tom hopper as albert
wesker and lily gao as aydah wong the
2021 edition also integrated a few game
characters who had never previously been
featured in the films like neil
mcdonough as umbrella virologist william
birkin and donald logue as raccoon city
chief of police brian irons one element
the latest film shares with the previous
installments is practical effects
director paul jones he also created
nemesis in resident evil apocalypse and
the axe men for afterlife and
retribution and there you have it
everything you need to know about the
history of resident evil from our evil
residents to yours so until next time
don't forget your healing herbs watch
out for liquors and keep it here on rt
essentials for more slow methodical
walks down the long dark terrifying
zombie filled corridors of film history
i'm mark ellis and we'll see you real
soon
[Music]
[Music]